re た
[音楽]
dj
tee
こんにちは定在波からの
初めて超皆さんがパソコンにウイルスやハッキングされたことありますか
僕は
もちろんありませんされたことないんですけどウィジェットのハッキングとかっていつ
されるか分からないんですよ本当にパソコンを使っている人だったら誰だってあり得る
ことなので今回はその教育をターゲットに体感してもらおうと思います
名付けてパソコンが遠隔操作によりハッキングされすごい
強くなっちゃうドッキリ
[音楽]
というわけでマックのパソ僕昨日で実はですね知ってる人は知ってると思うんですけど
も遠隔操作ができますとかのパソコンで操作できるように
そして監視できるように設定していきたいとおもいます
プレスいい
[音楽]
ブーブーブーブー erotica
というわけでこのパソコンにはすでに
リモートコントロールを仕掛けている股間パーセント常にだり遠隔操作で愛することが
できますだがターゲットはそれに気づいていない見えてください
まったくさんってないっすよ march これですからね
ご覧ください遠隔操作しております全く浮か去っていないけども
関連が勝手に動くこれが
そういうふうにターゲットが来るのでお楽しみん
ああああああん
どうぞ
ねえわけです
話
ございましたん
ないね何年
なぜかパズドラさんある程度できたからさー
もうちょいやっぱりでちょっとアップすれたられるとほぼほぼ完成ですねっ
と思いません
これはないとおっしゃっていいですか大丈夫ん
[音楽]
can touch
イヤホンはあ
おいん
でこれ何の勝ちですかぁー日刊紙か
いやーこれ今回貢いだな夕刊紙
[音楽]
国家なん
待ってバグったエマグったーいっ
あーなジョブの
4人女性うん
僕 avery
って俺は思ってです
ねえねえおかしい
10年して1回廻すでもまーすがあったどど家の家系ちゃ
ヒューンって言っ
留連する奴もないメディア
さあ ok ウケるん
[音楽]
んん
ここで持ってきてるぞねえねえねえ
ナッキーちゃったねー
ねぇ
あっ
[音楽]
ブーバへ
ねぇ聞いてるッ
cross my pure nude いるんだよああ
何だいないまあこれを得滑走も多くなカスタムを受けたねー
おかしいじゃん jal から飼ってるだろうけど
ナムくらいなんで
今自分ででしょペグって来季で振ってね関連素敵な道具でもよくこれここはフェアじゃ
ねぇほらほらほらほら
何をしてるん
産んでほしい寄ってっ
よねーっ何コレ yes
ちょさっきからなんかね矢印が勝ってる国って思ったんですよ
また来ねーねーねーねーねーねー
何々をしてが弦を得られ year
何ない
なお負けないのどうぞてないですよねっ
昇るほてぃんぐ
待つ待つ待つ対抗する対抗するこれやばいやばいんじゃない誰だよやめてねー
ウールガーゼ
そうじゃないんだラム4
うわぁ全部決するこいつはやば誰でははいたぁああやばいねえねえこれ大丈夫なん
多分
ねどっかから遠隔されてるんだよ多分ええんか食っても熱くないな
キレイは退けそれあなたは誰ですかみたいな赤い魔ができる
でも個人情報もネジある程度でどうすんだこれを持ってんの
うん白されるん
ペップ rw はマジじゃん野望
[音楽]
えっ
どうすんだこれ
ビッ
なんええ勝つ時代も宮廷音楽シャットダウンされたん
ねぇ
ねっ
もしよっ部屋だな
ガク捜査時日でした
[音楽]
お前だーなぁはい俺が著者として受けた
スーパーカラー maja セッターんねっ
そう